because I asked man and how do you know
everything what did what did they teach
you in school the women back then were
taught how to cook they were taught how
to iron clothes they were taught all the
important things of running a household
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
why would like what I would like to say
is um I think we're all in agreement
that men if we do come home and our wife
is is having trouble and she asked me
she asked me Michael can you you know
can you please help me I'm not going to
turn around and go no that's your job
I'll always turn around and as a matter
of fact I'm the person to go do you know
what honey don't worry about it I'll
I'll do the rest of it and I'll finish
it because that's that's my mindset I'm
a working man I'll come home and I'll
say don't worry you go to bed I've got
this the kids I'll do it don't worry
that's my personality one thing I will
say though is I think a lot of modern
day women in my opinion especially
Western women with the women here white
women my people they don't understand
the value of being in the kitchen I know
that sounds it's very I know it's a very
harsh as a white woman I actually agree
with that I think it's very uh it's a
it's a very it's a very valuable place
to be because as a working man you come
home you come home to a dinner you come
home so things already done for you we
look at you and we think wow I'm working
for we value you so great much more than
the woman we come home we don't want to
argue with you one because I've been
around masculine energy all day I don't
want to come home I'm not arguing with
you and you're irritating me now I don't
even want to talk to you you're
irritating me now furthermore that
that's my that's my point I do want to
say what I do want to say sorry brother
sorry what I do want to say shout out to
my nan because I live with my nan she
she she
is she's she's very older Generation
Um housewife I come home traditional
housewife I come home and everything's
done for me I grew up my hand she
brought me in age of five she does
everything for me I come home hard work
whether it's whether it's carpentry out
and out in the field whatever it is it
doesn't matter I'll come home
everything's done for me and I think
I'll go up to bed or I'll have dinner
and I'm my clothes ironed my washing's
all done and I think to myself wow if I
can get a woman like that I have a Mrs
thank God I have a Missus and she
understands the value she's recently
became Muslim as well
it's one of those it's one of those
things where I will go to bed and I will
think to myself what an amazing woman
what a beautiful woman she's you know I
I think his I think it's very important
to teach because because I asked man and
how do you know what did what did they
teach you in school the women back then
were taught how to cook they were taught
how to iron clothes they were taught all
the important things of running a
household
take it easy they're not they're not
they're not they're not tall they're not
taught the important things now neither
men or women they don't have we're not
given we're not given roles
into the world until you deal with it
and then they're forced an iPad or a
phone in their face and young kids are
being brought up with the red pill and
the complete opposite so now you've got
two extreme size reaction and there's
none you can meet in the middle I
remember I remember two I remember a
year ago maybe a year and a half Andrew
Tate started blowing up I was a bit
younger I must have been like 20. I was
agreeing with everything he was saying
everything he was saying and then he
started to go on to the women yeah yeah
and he started talking about the women
and started talking about how women
should do this women should do that and
it's the it's an extreme it's an extreme
point of view and it's and it's that's
the red pill that that people that us
Brothers talk about I think I'm not
gonna lie is polluting the mind you need
you know that's why I listen to them to
my other Muslim Brothers